madame monsieur bonsoir c'est une grande
première en france le parquet de paris
en effet ouvert aujourd'hui une
information judiciaire pour blessures
involontaires cela dans une affaire liée
à l'amiante un rapport d'experts estime
et je vous le rappelle en juillet cas au
moins 2000 le nombre de décès dus à
l'amiante chaque année en france c'est
une décision qui risque donc de
provoquer de sérieux remous comme dans
la sphère du sang contaminé anne
consignes et et jean-françois hoffman
ont rencontré le retraité à l'origine de
cette plainte
la retraite de jean dalla torre aurait
pu être plus belle s'il n'y avait ce
cancer de la plèvre qui lui empoisonnent
l'existence c'est la maladie de
l'amiante diagnostiqué il ya deux ans
moi j'ai cru d'abord une erreur de
diagnostic
carrément et puis les l'hôpital quand
ils ont recherché des m'interroger on
est arrivés sur cette période où le
fêtait j'avais fréquenté
l'amiante
comme ces deux hommes jean a été
électricien pendant quatre ans il
intervenait dans des locaux amiantés
mais c'était il ya plus de 30 ans à
l'époque pas de combinaisons étanches
pas de masque rien que les
responsabilités soient établies oui
c'est certain c'est certain c'est
souhaitable
coordonnée par l'association des
victimes de l'amiante d'autres plaintes
que celle de jean dalla torre ont été
déposées en province leur but comprendre
pourquoi alors que la nocivité de
l'amiante est connu depuis 50 ans
industriels pouvoirs publics et
scientifiques autant tardé à prendre des
mesures selon nous les organismes de
veille sanitaire n'ont pas fait leur
travail je vais dire ils ont ils se sont
laissés circonvenir par les industriels
de l'amiante et ils n'ont pas réagi à
temps 50 ans de retard et alors
quand on regarde un petit peu l' affaire
du sang contaminé la vache folle
l'amiante ça commence à faire beaucoup
comme dans la sphère du sang contaminé
jean dalla torre et les autres victimes
ont porté plainte pour empoisonnement
mais le parquet n'a retenu dans cette
affaire que la qualification de
blessures involontaires